thank you
[Music]
welcome back to another careful boards
where we're working very careful boys
today okay so this question actually
came to me and Nikki's podcast that I'll
tell you a while ago like I want to say
like a year and a half ago but it's
something that I think about quite often
because it came from
uh one of our our one of our listeners
was I believe it was uh female to male
trans and they were asking me they're
like hey Steve so like you know I'm you
know transitioning right now and I
wanted to like I'm younger so I just
wanted to have some thoughts like you're
one of the only people that I listen to
and I'm like oh Jesus Christ but a lot
of pressure they're like no I'm curious
about like for you what it means to be a
man like so as I like make this
transition it's something that I've
already felt like I am already but I'm
I'm also getting older and I want to
know what you've like for you where it
is to be a man and I'm like damn that's
the [ __ ] deepest question I think
I've ever been asked who's the most
masculine person in this room well what
did you say to this person first off I
went like this and then I said I'm
[ __ ]
did you ask if that's on patreon uh no I
mean honestly I just said to me being in
man was always about like from from
growing up same [ __ ] looking at examples
like watching my dad watching my
grandfather it's like when somebody says
they're gonna do something you [ __ ]
do it and I don't know if that's I'm not
saying that's exclusive to men or
whatever it's just to me that was always
like big for like watching like
especially when you know maybe it's a
stupid man thing that we do but there is
something that we do where we like
emboss the font while we say something
and it's like hey
when you say you're gonna [ __ ] do
something do it that's what it's that
sounds very embossed yeah and you don't
have to by the way you don't have to
preface it like that you could just do
it but for some reason I I had it
branded yeah like your word is like your
boss yeah you gotta raise an eyebrow and
you got to give a very Stern handshake
yeah
but enough about what I think about it
I'm curious about what you guys think
that's definitely hard if um if you're
not
born into a family with a dad that's
kind of showing you the ropes I think
that's a lot of it usually does come
from like Father Figure types that's a
lot of the first initial like how to be
a man like literal where that comes from
but I think every man literally just a
product of their peers and the qualities
they like in other people men or women
so if there's things that you admire
about someone else and you want to adopt
that it's genderless really you know I
could end up being more I guess like
feminine to what a man thinks just
because there were qualities I liked in
feminine men or in you know other women
it doesn't really matter what do you
think Society deems what a man is
um you'd have to go to Disney for that
and depends on which circle of society
you hang out in yeah or which commercial
you're watching just just a narrative
that you've been hearing lately about
what a man is from there were toxic
stereotype when the 50s in the 50s it's
like smacking a woman in the face to put
her into place
today is bothering your son all [ __ ]
day keep texting him
that's what it [ __ ] takes huh suck
the [ __ ] out of your son
one of the one of the strongest things
societally is is uh keep your problems
to yourself and just deal with it yeah
figure it out [ __ ] up and uh you know
yeah just do the thing which is like the
thing that we're not supposed to tell
people to do nowadays anymore yeah yeah
so that's ironic but it was how I was
brought up so it gets tough it's not
it's not it's a reflex you know what I
mean sure yeah it's a reflex it's weird
I think um I was uh maybe because I also
grew up with a sister uh anytime
something needed to be physically done
it was like important for the boy to do
it literally my parents be like boy hey
you know what I mean it's like weather's
picking some groceries from the car and
bring them in the house I didn't have
the chance to be like what about her you
know what I mean it's like you're the
boy go like opening up pickle jars
exactly sure like whatever it is if it
took some sort of like extra physical
picture whatever
um you don't want the pickle bad enough
but I also need to be extreme
why do you buy the pickles what
don't really want something that's so
true they do shake like that and then
and then I'm like where's a man would I
need one dude why do [ __ ] love
pickles so much if they can't even get
themselves the shape
yeah but I will say I think though those
little things as a kid uh subconsciously
teach you that thing as an adult too uh
that transcends into places like um if
there is a a tense situation or like
maybe the idea of like an aggressor and
you know it's like you and your spouse
or your family where it's like as the
man also you gotta kind of be the first
and last line of defense you know what I
mean so I feel like that was something
that I was ingrained as well I don't
think my dad ever like said verbage wise
like you have to do this but I think
just through like the way that you get
brought up you know that that's your
role and responsibility it is weird
right when there's a noise in the night
it's like that's not me dude yeah yeah
I'm still scared but it's my job I'm
scared shitless and honestly pancaking
my pants right now yeah like I just
bisquicked my [ __ ] shorts
but what am I gonna do yeah you gotta go
do it being a man doesn't mean you don't
get to be afraid it just means you still
got to go do it you know what I mean
push it down still gotta do it push it
down and get the job done and that's it
what up guys this episode is brought to
you by audible I'm a big big fan of
audible because I love being efficient
with my time so every single time I'm
driving from Vegas back to LA or La back
to Vegas my go-to thing is pulling up my
Audible app and what's awesome about it
is you can even listen to books or
podcasts or original shows offline
because you know sometimes when you're
traveling you don't always have Wi-Fi
and right now a book that I really
really love is called Scar and Stripes
by Tim Kennedy my good friend and he
just documents like his whole upbringing
from him being a kid growing up in like
the NorCal area all the way to him going
to Afghanistan to help rescue people
during the entire like Afghanistan
Fiasco it's really cool because um not
only does he share all these experiences
and makes you feel very grateful to be
an American but also one of my favorite
things about audiobooks is that a lot of
times the author is the one that's
narrating it or reading it so you get
way more from the book because you get
emotion and a lot of the other things
rather than just hearing your own voice
and that's the book that I'm reading
right now and if you guys want any type
of audio entertainment go check out
audible because that's literally what
they're all about your One Stop shops
because they got audible Originals they
got podcasts they have books obviously
and like I was saying you can check out
one new title every single month so
it'll keep you entertained so let
audible help you discover new ways to
laugh Be Inspired or be entertained
because new members could try for free
for 30 days just go to audible.com off
the Record or just text off the Record
to 500-500 that's audible.com off the
Record or text off the Record to 500-500
to try Audible for free for 30 days
audible Dot com slash off the Record
what's your what's your take on this
like like like to bring you in and
honestly very curious about what you
think about yeah like what you think a
man is supposed to well I I grew up with
um a brother and a dad and I have leaned
more in in that realm so
um
I would say uh
typically it's to be a provider a
protector
um
a leader of sorts
um I think that's just kind of like the
foundation of what people are typically
brought up in as what a man should be or
wants to be
um
but I can't speak for men I'm a woman
start laughing
very brave how do you feel about it it's
all about dudes that talk about their
feelings all day yeah yeah how do you
feel about dudes that talk about women
on behalf of women that's all we do it
all the time yeah that's fine but we do
Applause for that too so yeah yeah uh
all day
that's the right answer
is it just Pockets yeah all day perfect
in Boston this [ __ ] spewing these
[ __ ] emotions all day what do you
think about that
what do you think about guys who are
criers
does that does that allowed to you I
mean give me the context what are you
crying about Dick Vermeil after an
Eagles game and he's like
we just did that what it takes out there
have you cried out of on a football game
like has a game made you cry honestly no
but I wish I was out of death
I really do have you ever cried in any
football scenario yeah not even after
finishing Remember the Titans no well if
you're watching movies I've cried in
like MMA and fight scenarios really so
uh and an MMA so Anderson Silva who was
like the considered widely by a goat by
many when he was fighting Izzy which is
the up-and-coming star at the time but a
very similar style like he's like
translating and doing all kinds of crazy
[ __ ]
when Izzy and Anderson Silva is his Idol
so it's almost like a passing of the
torch that he has to beat him when he
beat him and when they hugged and then
Izzy was crying because he doesn't want
to be this Idol but he has to be this
Idol when Anderson Silva uh whispered in
his ear like you're the next one
did you cry at ACC
IO he said you teared up at ADCC I think
I did well what was the moment
because of AOC
80cc
or combat Club it's the Olympics of
grappling Sports and it was in Vegas so
I had to go
and there was a so there's a guy named
Cyborg and he looks like a [ __ ] tank
freak of nature and he just looks like
he'll kill people he's a legend but he's
also like mid-40s so I think he's like
at the end of his career when he
um when he lost in the first round
and then he stood up like the entire
Stadium got up like because he was just
witnessing a legend like but you can
tell that the sport has evolved past him
so it's like he was a monster of his day
it's like almost like seeing Mike Tyson
getting beat the first time and but
everyone was so like gracious to see
like we've witnessed your career so the
entire Stadium like stood up and
everyone gave him a standing ovation
even though he lost oh my God
you actually just reminded me I did cry
during a football thing when Peyton
Manning got released from the Colts and
he gave his speech and he's like I will
always be a cult I was like God damn
it got me good God damn do these stories
sound weird to you are you like why the
[ __ ] are you crying let's not cry worthy
to each their own if it
that emotional then cry all day about it
I also cried during The Blind Side I was
like oh my God white people were so
great
they're great are we great
answer the guy next to me we're great
huh
last time you cried Anthony and why to
be a man man oh oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah you're asking the wrong dude but
thank you for for circling back to me
Colleen yeah you're welcome I just felt
like you know you you would have a good
answer you know I don't have a really
good answer honestly
um because
that's such a loaded question
a beacon of manhood to you for you or no
man in a way yes but also
no well yeah yeah I'll say yes but
sometimes I I battle with it too because
growing up like my dad was in my life
but he was always kind of like
off to the side you know like he was
always kind of like doing his own thing
so I think I was mostly influenced
by my sister's growing up because I was
the youngest and I had two older sisters
they were like six and seven years above
me and my mom
so for me like earlier in my life I felt
like I related more with women all the
time anyway it wasn't until I started
training and like trying to fight and
compete that I was like finding myself
in rooms full of men you know so
and with all the guys I train with I did
find little aspects like what Ryan
talked about where oh I really admire
this thing about this guy I really
admire this thing about this dude and I
would take bits and pieces from
everybody and they're all different
walks of life all kinds of guys
different professions but I would always
just kind of be like a sponge and just
try to soak up what these guys had to
say about like it maybe wasn't directly
about like being a man or anything like
that but those are things that you
observe of how their character is how
they treat other people how they act in
the grand scheme of uh women children
and everybody else so I think a lot of
ways I I do agree a lot with what Ryan
said about how it's like what you admire
what you think is maybe within your
moral compass or what is right or wrong
and you kind of just take what you think
you admire and then you move on with
that so I think
that summed it up the most for me to
have a strong philosophy a personal
philosophy a moral code yeah because
then man or man or woman like yeah
there's differences of course but I
don't think they're that different from
each other right like
I mean I still can't open up a pickle
jar I know and that's a problem right
that's a problem and I have a grip
string Pro a grip strength training
program that we'll have and we can make
that yeah it's only for men it makes
modifications but it's that Lionheart
Jiu Jitsu so like you know [ __ ] oh she
didn't even think about that
no but yeah I think it's a combination
what about
chivalry
I believe in it yeah I believe in it too
I I get the door for Nikki dude that
[ __ ] will [ __ ] scream me and
screaming
we'll be somewhere she's taking my
[ __ ] head off about something I mean
this was years ago I do have a
particular memory of this just took my
[ __ ] head off about something and
then like she still like goes the door
and I still open the door and [ __ ]
we'll let her again close the door
because to me that's just what it's all
about it's about respect that's what
it's about it's not because girls can't
get doors I don't know what that's about
with social media these days I can get
the door it's like yeah we all know you
can open a [ __ ] just say thank you
yeah well you don't even have to say
things are it's like that you should
expect it to me you should expect this
like it's just like it's the thing like
it's like yeah you know you get the door
doors are dirty you're being polite like
yeah that's it guys do it for other guys
too yeah I hold the door open for
everybody and if you know they don't say
thank you I say [ __ ] you close the door
and you say walk I think I think I just
don't do it for handicapped people
because I'm like you shouldn't have even
been in here yeah they take too long to
get to the door use the button I'm sorry
don't you have your own door
give your own little door down yeah
[Laughter]
foreign